I brought my kids to the mall,
and I swear to god, someone stopped me on the way in and said,
oh, my god,
what are you wearing? That's so cute?
And I was like, Laura,
look at this thing. Perfect for the hot summer.
It's got big, wide,
baggy legs so you're not, like, hot.
The material is really light,
and it's. It is kind of like windbreakery,
so it's very thin and light.
It's totally manageable in this fucking heat.
And look at how nice you look.
This jumpsuit is every. It's got big,
deep pockets.
It's fitted up here so you, like,
look small, but then it's got these big,
wide, baggy legs so you're not too hot.
I swear, this jumpsuit is.
Everything is linked right here.
It is fucking perfect for this hot summer.